you know after it listed it tanked but
ever since then it's kind of gone up and
up and up
it seems investors love this song
absolutely a big thumbs up or a like if
you will rich from shareholders because
we did see that record high coming
through Facebook shares rising above
ninety US dollars a night overnight now
this is just a month after we actually
saw Facebook knock Walmart off the top
ten companies by market value a lot of
analysts and investors weren't too sure
that this company had staying power as
you mentioned it had o quite a big fall
after its IPO in fact it lost about half
of its value in four months in the first
four months of trading but since then up
two hundred and eighteen percent
Facebook shares in three years they're
up about thirty five percent
year-to-date so certainly a lot of
investors staying into this stock and
realizing that it does have legs it does
have longevity and of course really just
a record once again 250 billion market
cap to put that into perspective Walmart
and Procter & Gamble took decades to get
to that level and of course now it's in
that top 10 market cut value as well
well I mean the thing is it's hard
enough to get there but it's probably
been harder to maintain that that type
of capitalization isn't it so you know
what does it need to do is I mean it's
it was nowhere mobilize a year and a
half ago that's the biggest push now
isn't it absolutely an advertising
obviously but particularly on that
mobile device and they've got a really
good algorithm so if you look for
something on Google then basically the
ads are going to come up in your feed of
what you've been searching so there
worked incredibly well with advertisers
to have that come up and really tailored
to each user but also of course they get
a lot of their sales from advertising in
fact sales were up 46 percent in the
quarter to three point three two billion
dollars well above what analysts were
looking for so this stock just continues
to I guess beat market expectations also
all those acquisitions so of course they
took whatsapp messenger their own
messenger system and the reason they
acquired what's up was because nobody
was really using messenger so they
wanted to get the whole market and
Instagram and then other apps that you
have to use dating apps for example you
have to log in through Facebook so
everybody has to have a Facebook account
if they want one of these apps and
that's what's really keeping them
profitable long term